attention attention
riou taiwo devrait embrasser dia main
sur la bouche a jamais rentré et voilà
cette attention
en ce que le plein en tout seul c'est
assez attendait pas été comme ça et
offre comme un fennec et là car la carte
de djamel maintenant
alors qu'arte merci allégations de luc
besson pour lui demander ce qu'il faut
dire absolument sur la promo du film
d'accord voir certains n'a pas eu notre
carte mission impossible vous devez
successivement dire du bien de laurent
gerra et du mil du mal de zinedine
zidane 60 possible alors je vais appeler
luc laluque on en direct à la télévision
il ya tous les genres tous les gens de
tout le monde en plaques
bien venir y aller robin il ya laurent
baffie il ya stomy bugzy aussi mais ça
veut dire que tu es à la télé a toujours
autant de monde autour de toi tu parles
de demain ma chambre
est ce que je peux te bouges pas de
poser une question qu'est-ce qu'il faut
que je dise pour que pour la promo du
film
c'est ça ma mission là j'ai un défi faut
que je te demande à travers ce qu'il
faut que je dise
pour donner envie aux gens de venir il
dit que les gens au chaud en ce moment
de passer une heure trente avec une
magnifique plante ou trois heures avec
un gorille vous choisissez ah oui c'est
bien
hewson
c'est le vin
légende d'un sénat